russian troops are advancing through
ukraine
what follows is likely to be europe's
most intense war in a generation
the aim is regime change is to topple
the government in kiev and that's what
we're seeing happening here
what might happen next
and what does this mean for the world
i'd like to get your perspective on this
um because what none of us thought would
actually happen except it must be said
you shashank uh has happened so is it a
trial run for further aggression by
russia and putin i mean is he going to
go beyond kiev what i've seen in recent
days as the invasion became more
apparent and then as it occurred is
quite serious credible sober voices on
foreign policy who um you know don't
don't um sensationalize these things
asking themselves that question where is
he going to stop
our baseline assumption about putin's
appetite for risk and his ambition and
his
judgment the way his cost benefit
calculated calculus works has changed in
recent days and i think that requires us
to
raise the possibility however small of a
russian challenge going onto nato
territory profit talk us through the
scenarios of escalation what do you
worry about most the ones that worry me
most in terms of real concrete tangible
escalation risks are simply the fact of
having uh 190 000 russian troops in
close proximity to nato forces
and neither side has to seek a
confrontation for escalation to be a
problem we have already seen how
vladimir putin is using the manipulation
of risk to try and get nato to back down
he said in the same blood-curdling
speech in which he declared war on early
thursday morning that uh um uh he hinted
at nuclear consequences he talked about
escalation uh and and direct attacks on
the west and i think it's important that
while understanding these risks have to
be managed nato also realizes there is
no deterrence without some risk and that
all policies carry risk
and russia cannot have a monopoly on
elevating it and using it to get the
other side to back down
al-qaeda do you think that western
sanctions thus far have passed the
credibility test
they might have passed the credibility
test as far as the west is concerned i
was talking to um
my friends and kiev
yesterday and we have three
correspondents there
and the sense of
uh
abandonment
by a lot of them you're saying
we are in the heart of europe we are
being shelled we are being killed and
the west is dithering and introducing
the sort of small steps this is
this is fundamentally about values i
think the west um and the public needs
to
recognize that it's the moment of its
own making that actually the west needs
to do it not just for the sake of
ukraine it needs to do it for its own
sake of self-respect and holding
together all those things that provide
the foundation of political systems in
europe one of the many ways in which
vladimir putin could react is through
unconventional means so cyber warfare as
you yourself said in particular how well
is the west prepared for russian hackers
hitting key targets it's a lot better
prepared than it has been in the past um
and of course we should remember it was
a russian cyber operation
that um
made the 2016 u.s presidential election
so contested and so difficult so there
is a concern
but what i would say to all of that is
that in general russia's intention here
is probably to try and signal to the
west stay out of this conflict it isn't
to try and do something that would draw
the west in the thresholds that russia
applies are still going to be sensible
they're still going to be calculating
they're not going to just sort of blow
things up during the u.s in a spasm of
violence or cyber-enabled violence for
no reason strategy is still at work here
so i think we shouldn't sort of think
all of a sudden there's going to be a
huge cyber blow russia will use these in
calibrated cautious ways to signal to
the west and to hit back and to deter
further actions
the the key aspect here is nato's
article 5 uh principle the idea that if
one member of nato is attacked that
they're they're all attacked and that's
the basis on which
nato security fundamentally lies and do
you think those unconventional attacks
would amount to something that would
trigger article five the short answer is
no uh article five is about an armed
attack in in nato it is possible uh zany
to imagine cyber attacks that could
reach the threshold of article five
those for example that disabled key
military forces that caused serious
physical damage to infrastructure and it
is possible for cyber attacks to cause
that kind of damage but i would say much
more likely is
for cyber attacks in the cognitive space
disinformation propaganda confusion
things that sort of uh are much lower
down the threshold than those which
would cross article five
but i can see
scenarios in which let's take cyber war
which lethal things happen where it's
unclear whether that threshold's been
reached and if that happens you can
imagine putin testing the strength of
this bond and trying to find fissures
and splits within nato that mean that
actually that article 5 becomes less
credible
it's not something that happens quickly
it happens gradually over a number of
years so if you get a disagreement
between nato members about whether
whether to go with article 5 or not the
whole alliance is weakened
do you agree do you agree that that is a
possibility i mean that's a
fundamentally scary thought i think that
that commitment is only as credible and
robust as people believe it is and so if
putin has recast the map of europe by
changing a regime in kiev to his liking
by changing the status quo in belarus
weakening the position the military
position and the defensibility of the
baltic states and of poland uh perhaps
even by sending refugees flooding into
those states casting a shadow over the
independence of of moldova uh which has
long had an area occupied by russian
forces um
then yes that is a threat to article
five uh one thing that has um has i've
been wondering about is just how much
china knew about gave the nod to or was
surprised by what vladimir putin has
done do you think china is
actively supporting russia i think uh
china is guided by three principles one
is its its alliance with russia against
the united states in particular
uh another is its principle of
non-interference
and the third is its desire
um not to be affected by sanctions and
those three things are impossible or to
pursue all at once at the same time so
it has to make some very difficult
choices and i think in the end the one
that it will sacrifice is its principle
of of non-interference so i think it
will help russia um but there's no doubt
that it's uncomfortable
about all of this and i don't think this
is something that china has engineered
or planned or encouraged russia to do
and let's now turn to de-escalation
because i want to see if there are ways
that or how you think this can be
de-escalated and al-qaeda let's get your
sense of that
do you see
a path
where putin will de-escalate i'm afraid
to say that
i think the only way in which he would
escalate is
if he does
has a sense of real
resistance any sign of weakness and
appeasement
would only invite further attack all the
evidence all the imperial evidence
suggests that only strong response is
likely to stop vladimir putin putin is
not the bravest man he is much more of a
thug
who goes where he's allowed to go so i
think the only way to de-escalate uh in
my view is to build a very serious
incredible set of deterrence and being
able uh to hold that line
this is actually uh sort of decisive
moment um
for europe and for russia itself
uh taking kiev bombing kiev um the
cradle of russian cities you know uh
the center of
ancient civilization is is it's a step
which um
which could have absolutely
unpredictable consequences we're in
uncharted waters here
to read more about the war in ukraine
please click the link to visit our hub
where you'll find all of our coverage
thanks again for watching and don't
forget to subscribe